thousand gallon rez my name is Pierre
and welcome to [ __ ] back to Concord bad
[ __ ] de Ternay whatever don't judge
don't be hatin brush you bros are such
hateful people I never know with you
anyway it's ten o'clock I think I do ten
o'clock for you are you watching that
that would be awesome Canadian because
we're going to that [ __ ] house or
whatever that opens at ten o'clock I
don't know what it's called it could be
anything it could be a pharmacy it could
be a I I can't play Scrabble thought so
of course I can't think of anything else
anyway I think it's here kids thinks
he's here what do you think Damien's pin
strikes again is it here is it this that
could be a pharmacy you know say you
shouldn't be so hateful all the time
going in wedding gas masks that's how I
roll don't even know what I'm Cal call
call
well I'm sorry oh it's decide to
scientist I'm looking at your beautiful
pink robe it's so awesome
oh I think I can
that's a cat-like behavior I get the
feeling the Grim Reaper it's gonna kill
the cat
yeah you're a genius you found the
answer
all right cool yeah uh-huh uh-huh you
analyze the table closely as I have done
most particularly trouble there there's
a gap my god uh-huh
it is indeed a sizeable jack uh-huh what
happens we have the full gun yeah it's
not even the same [ __ ] table
wait no good because our fat cat genius
scientist okay
zag app smart today smart getting the
solution ah this is bad gets cold
oh [ __ ] if it gets complicated I know if
I can keep up I tried many things I've
tried a flower oh thanks
uh-huh one thing and I was sure of it at
the time I was 700 the square of which
Terius Furya Scuderi but Funaki good for
the layman serve red sky
Thanks ya know I'm a red scar oh [ __ ]
we're [ __ ]
I heard of them to actually wait I am
one sure so it's a central militia we
need a school and V button yeah
genius genius Bravo
Nobel Prize award right there oh my jet
really bad they don't look like
gentlemen
they look like squirrels kind of kind of
handicapped squirrels dun-dun-dun they
don't look dick are they holding hands
are they a gay couple that's okay that's
okay they want to be a gay couple that's
a handicap be a squirrel couple I see
what's in here
you never know what's gonna be next in
this [ __ ] game ready go thank God huh
smell why should I set anyway you
watchin poo um no cows get them in there
get them to crap
I'll make eat a bowl of poop you can do
what the hell you like you honey break
what charming child Meg
oh [ __ ] you love conquer but seriously
what the [ __ ] what I'd even follow
through it what the [ __ ] alright good
thing I had my gas mask over whatever
the [ __ ] I'm doing Jesus Christ conquer
you i won where dat son of flower no ah
conquer now you come back here that's
fine love they love the soundtrack it's
it's a very artistic there it is going
Borat oh this one even higher - all
right nail that [ __ ] let's just go go
with this for now it looks like an exit
hallelujah this whole place has that
exit I would have thought what a thing
it that's not a [ __ ] Cowell you know
right don't see any poo here oh hey
excuse me hello yeah you oh [ __ ]
hello friendly type I'm looking for some
realist [ __ ] story ever in it I'm
actually orange come on but I'm orange a
kid even like red what I don't do
anything right around Oh may we go again
here we go again indeed boss battle let
the final battle begin gonna grab that
chocolatey bar oh I agree cocky look
sometimes when he runs he's so angry and
vicious while running you are an angry
little squirrel aren't you all right so
you get health care from the sides I
guess we gotta fight him somehow
hey I'm a squirrel it does not mean you
have to get run Rock that was a close
one
stupid balls don't even know what you're
doing what's going on down here
what is that smacking sound so IQ like
well there's something over here let's
check this out
all right here we go what the [ __ ] is
that
gotta hurry up now oh they stopped
that's wonderful
dot no there's more oh that it aren't
those ones where we're looking for the
ball of / right
[ __ ] sake how many posts can there be
all right here we go here we go pop-up
is stalking ha get that big that big
that now what do we do with you huh I
run in this direction as [ __ ] doctor
Jani has been strikes again my god what
the [ __ ] is that diarrhea period and me
know now logic would denote that's
something that drinks that it's gonna
get the screaming squid oh just think
you like a target and doesn't gain yeah
I think I get it I don't get it
Pitts don't get it someone explained to
him oh wait I'm playing I need to know
this [ __ ]
alright well I have all the chocolatey
bars that's it we could just go wander
off here in the desert
no it's slippery boo son of a [ __ ] just
hide with boots slippery and you fall
all over it what I like to do is I make
us nothin poo angel you know like you're
doing snow I do it I do that [ __ ] in poo
all right where's the target
there it is all right now mr. bolt red
you and I should dance the tango [ __ ]
you [ __ ] you
no tango for you come at me bro come at
me bro
that's right bro oh [ __ ] it's a sexy cow
mama don't tell me I gonna have to
witness right this looks like it but I
think I'm gonna more hands-on control
he's a bit of a while um hmm that kind
no say Baba lovely lying again cruel
best nice little patch something look at
the clip dress move big air over there
somehow hmm
I love the Spanish sunshine all right
all right there there it is oh [ __ ] it's
so evil shut up
alright so pressing B will make him like
[ __ ] charger shed so you're supposed
to charge on that [ __ ] that's right you
[ __ ] yeah you [ __ ]
yo bit I'm a little pissed I played that
for like 30 minutes now I'm gonna go
little man Jerome yeah but then it would
did your voice action it should watch
this histogram you just [ __ ] drink
that diary I feel it cranberry flavored
yeah
this [ __ ] engulf that [ __ ] just drink
that shed it's good for you I may die I
made that oh oh oh oh oh good heavens
I'm a fox a Maeve is an olive you never
know indeed ready to go
looks like about ready to go what are we
doing and we're gonna singer again stick
that Bo come on man I only have one
chocolate bar now oh that's quite lovely
there's two chocolatey bars over hey
oh I'm chocolate bar hum too hot let you
back well and next early pair that way
we'll have to jump up here again oh
she's still [ __ ] again CJ oh okay that
was quick alright I'm a charging Mic
Check
whoa I am me to [ __ ] kill her are the
[ __ ] targets are back I didn't see
that where are you there you are how
could I not see I'm an idiot
son another [ __ ] cow are you serious
are you serious I have to do this [ __ ]
again one time wasn't enough [ __ ] shut
up
pips is pissed now there's a pitch pill
get update can't up day get up there get
in there get it back get in there by
Fred God I'm not God I'd done what is it
playing game boy
[ __ ] you conquer I wanna play game I get
in that if pets
there we go JIT why are you tickling all
right where's the cow [ __ ] stuck that
[ __ ]
oh you got a blonde so go down whoa [ __ ]
did a 360 like that [ __ ] are you gonna
go and have diarrhea you're moving get
it moving ha ha ha ha ha what the [ __ ]
is your problem
hate the cranberry diarrhea alright if I
miss from here I'm [ __ ] stupid
that's right [ __ ] what
get the [ __ ] over yeah just shut that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] you [ __ ] [ __ ]
ciao ciao ciao I love her face
ah [ __ ] no no no that's how I should by
the way in case you were cares what's
your [ __ ] face wonderful you look quite
beautiful when you make a [ __ ] face just
want to point that out
oh well oh well II Willy Willy Willy
we're not another [ __ ] cow place I
don't know why you're such a fat bastard
who's gonna de bastard
that took me 40 minutes since the be
fill up with poo that [ __ ] get like that
should do it quite splendid quite nice
am I supposed to jump down here it's
that really well [ __ ] it then
Yolo jumping down in [ __ ] that was
funny because you know up we get an
extra tail for that [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah [ __ ]
yeah another tail it [ __ ]
well [ __ ] we filled up the shirt with
[ __ ] I don't know what I feel about this
chocolate from the toilet but hey we're
taking it anyway we completed this
mission and I want to [ __ ] finish it
I really have to stop like I want to
keep playing but I can't I have to stop
playing but so yeah lack of that right
after and I do it subscribe enjoy a
scenic desert away you have pretty eyes
today aha
I don't know what's happened to me back
at the door behind me